Do You Know But Their Cell Therapy Anything You Are
Promising Therapy Games Cancer Also
Non S Koi Blue Color Because They Can Kill Anybody
In Dewar Path Their Cells Are Also Promising
Candidate Against Virus
Immunity De Scientist
Per Fighting Games
Tumor Cell Express Tumor Antigen
Scientist Can Generate  Specific Antibodies Which
Food Targets and Marks
These Tumor Cells for Destruction These Cells Have Receptor Which Can
Recognize These Antibodies and
Mount Immune Response Against These
Tumor Cells These Foods Eventually Secret
Substances Which Food Destroys
Tumor Cells and Others by Doing You Sing D
Tumor It  Haj bin show me current research was
their cell therapy is almost 73% efficient
and success rate is pretty high so
subscribe to my channel.